pas reste-t-il sinon flammes et en
irlande on va évidemment parler ou en
étau en europe où en est-on en france
quarante ans après la loi veil la
bataille et elles gagnent et pourquoi
par exemple on se posera la question
le nombre d'avortements ne baisse-t-il
plus dans notre pays on va parler de
tout ça d'abord avec camilla mais
l'aquarelle réalisatrice de de ce film
avec la sénatrice communiste brigitte
gonthier maurin qui rapporte deux
rapporteurs pas très joli alors à passer
mieux du projet de loi dit d'égalité
réelle qu'ils ont gagné à supprimer la
notion de détresse lors du recours à
l'avortement
la gynécologue marie laure brival de la
maternité des lilas près de paris ancien
président de l'association des centres
d'interruption de grossesse
le chercheur laurent tout le monde
responsable de l'unité fécondité famille
et sexualité à l'institut national des
études démographiques et puissent sabine
jourdan bénévoles de l'association agape
à une association chrétienne des coudes
des femmes notamment des femmes qui ont
eu recours à l'avortement pour les aider
à faire le deuil
camilla mais d'abord vous êtes une jeune
femme vous avez quel âge 27 ans 27 ans
pour une jeune française de 27 ans le
droit d'avoir avorté c'est une évidence
si vous le souhaitez quoi vous en
pensiez par ailleurs mais c'est une
évidence pourquoi vous êtes intéressé à
ce qui se passe en irlande comment avez
vous su ce qui se passait en irlande
parce que beaucoup de français
l'ignorent justement j'étais dans cette
situation on arrive à en irlande en 2008
comme vous l'avez dit j'ai grandi avec
le droit à l'avortement dans mon pays et
je suis arrivé donc en 2008 et en
irlande et je me disais je ne sais pas
pourquoi c'était peut-être très naïf de
ma part j'avais seulement 20 ans et donc
avec mac os réalisatrice serena robin on
arrivé là bas en en ayant l'impression
que en irlande aussi c'était c'était une
évidence à cause de l'union européenne
on est dans cet état d'esprit là et on
s'est rendu compte que c'était qu'on
avait tout faux donc évidemment on a été
assez choqués puisque l'irlande c'est
quand même un pays très proche du nôtre
beaucoup beaucoup de deux points de vue
et
et voilà cette idée est resté avec nous
pendant plusieurs années on dit même que
vous avez été hanté par cette oui c'est
quelque chose qui nous a vraiment qu'on
a été vraiment très touché par par la
situation des femmes là-bas c'est
quelque chose qui nous a vraiment en
tant que jeune femme énormément touchés
donc on est rentré en france on a
poursuivi nos études
serena s'est orienté vers le cinéma et
moi vers le journalisme et on s'est dit
c'est trop bête de ne pas faire ce film
ce film qu'on a tellement envie de faire
mettons nos compétences en commun et
faisant ce film les femmes qu'on entend
qu'on voit d'ailleurs derrière vous pour
l'une d'entre elles sont pour la plupart
des militantes pro choice comme on dit
c'est à dire pour le droit à
l'avortement elles elles sont devenues
devenue quelque part puisque quand on a
vécu quelque chose comme ça en effet une
des solutions pour le surmonter je pense
que c'est ça peut être aussi la
politique
donc dans le cas dont des personnages
jar jar et gueye par exemple le couple
qui a perdu son enfant à 22 semaines
euh je pense qu'ils n'étaient plus
n'avait pas un profil de militants à la
base c'est du fait de leur souffrance du
fait de leur ai tout voilà leur enfant
était condamné donc voilà exactement
donc c'est à cause de leurs souffrances
et de leur histoire qu'ils se sont
orientés vers le vert le militantisme je
suis frappé de scooby doo me dit ils ont
perdu leurs enfants à 22 il le gif comme
ça parce que eux c'était un enfant ce
couple il le voulait cet enfant c'était
leur premier il venait de se marier il
était heureux c'était la nouvelle de la
danse et fally donc du foetus du fait
qu'il ne survivrait pas peut-être même
pas à la grossesse n'est en tout cas pas
à l'accouchement
c'était une vraie tragédie pour donc
donc l'avortement dans ce cas là c'est
c'est peut-être d'ailleurs dans d'autres
cas mais dans leur cas à eux c'était
vraiment une perte et un deuil ensuite
c'était moi ils ont été faciles à
convaincre non non mais on peut les
comprendre là bas c'est vraiment c'est
comme si on a du mal à le comprendre
c'est pour ça je vous poserai voilà je
sais que d'un point de vue français on
n'y a pas une telle chape de plomb sur
le sujet même si voilà évidemment il ya
des opinions encore assez tranchées et
caetera et qu'il ya un débat
heureusement mais mais il ya passé de
chape de plomb qui en irlande on
pourrait elle prendre la parole à visage
découvert avec leur nom
c'est pas une décision à prendre à la
légère et ses jeux on les trouve
vraiment très courageuse et j'espère que
ça se ressent dans le film mais c'est
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
courage de prendre la parole sur ce
qu'il n'ya pas d'avortement clandestin
pratiqué en irlande n'aurait que l'on
sache pas qu'on peut évidemment
évidemment qu'on pourrait
malheureusement avoir connaissance ça
s'est passé en france à l'époque mais en
face aux dangers de décès de femmes à la
suite de d'avortement enfin sonné
c'était un secret de polichinelle
oui en irlande il n'ya vraiment pas du
tout de traces
après ça dépend ce qu'on appelle en
fortement clandestins on sait qu'il ya
des femmes comment de la pilule abortive
sur internet notamment et qu'il apprenne
seuls dans leur chambre
ces clandestins au sens où c'est
interdit mais ce n'est pas la même la
même situation qu'en france avant les
années encore une fois répétons le ce
n'est pas puni d'aller avorter à
l'étranger ce qui va les lui ça ne l'est
plus depuis 92 12 salles est en revanche
ça le saurai d'avorter sur le soleil à
l'anglais oui et d'une lourde peine 14
ans d'emprisonnement où en est-on du
combat dont vous dites un mois la fin du
documentaire où en est-on du débat
politique en y allant la situation n'a
pas évolué depuis la fin du tournage
claire délit la politicienne qu'on voit
dans le film a tenté de à proposer une
loi au parlement qui autoriserait
l'avortement justement en cas de
malformation fatale du foetus
aujourd'hui on le répète un viol ou bien
mise en danger de la vie de la mère
n'ont même pas le viol même pas le viol
a le geste que j'avais cru comprendre
non seulement en cas de mise en danger
imminent de la vie de la mère celle état
suicidaire c'est ce qu'on voit la cerda
s'est associé à celui-ci
c'est compliqué quand même et puis c'est
honnêtement c'est dans les faits
personne n'apporte en irlande la loi a
été faite de je trouve on trouve avec
serena que et on n'est pas les seuls à
le penser que la loi est faite de
manière à ce que ça soit impossible en
fait d'eux de se servir de cette loi
pour avorter c'était c'est trop
compliqué sur les parole très forte
qu'on entend dans le documentaire que
j'ai ressenti beaucoup d'émotion et me
dire quelle inhumanité
comment est ce que c'est encore possible
même si je ne suis pas naïve
si je sais que ce combat des femmes pour
accéder aux droits reproductifs et sahel
dont fait partie l'avortement est un
combat de longue haleine et sera un
combat est un combat du quotidien qu'il
ne faut surtout pas lâcher on y compris
en france
le frappant parce que le documentaire
commence par des images de simone veil
et des manifestations dans les rues de
france mais il ya plus de 40 ans et
elles sont suivies de manifestations en
irlande aujourd'hui le décalage dont en
europe et encore mobilisation dans notre
pays pour empêcher des centres de
planning familial ou même des maternités
de clore leurs portes faute de moyens
donc c'est un combat actuel il ya les
paroles très brutale des situations
décrites de manière très crue dans votre
documentaire on dit souvent take the
boat évidemment on a compris que c'était
prendre l'avion pour l'angleterre
revenir dans la foulée après avoir reçu
un traitement abortif généralement mes
guides médicamenteux évidemment ça n'est
jamais une lettre à la poste
écoutez et irlandaises
sabine jourdan je me tourne vers vous
parce que votre association est une
association chrétienne et que clairement
ce qui est mis en cause là c'est la
culture catholique traditionnelle de
l'irlande
est ce que comme chrétiens nous est
choquée d'entendre ce qui vient d'être
dit j'ai été bouleversé par le film sur
tous ces témoignages
parce que ce que j'ai envie de dire
c'est pas quelle que soit la position de
votre association pour aux comptes
l'avortement ça n'est pas le sujet chez
vous nous ne sommes pas dans une
position où on écoute on est dans
l'accueil l'accueil des personnes qui
souffrent il en a donc on accueille et
on écoute on accompagne personnes qui
souffrent voilà c'est c'est vraiment
l'objectif tout à fait premier et
essentiel d'agapes 1 on est pas des
militantes et on n'est pas des fais pas
de prosélytisme
aucun on a que tout le monde tous les
âges
les personnes qui viennent il n'ya pas
c'est vraiment de tous les âges de
toutes confessions de tous milieux
sociaux
toute personne il ya ce sentiment chez
celles que vous accueillez de rejet de
solitude extrême
j'allais dire de punition pardonner
parce que c'est le mot qui me vient à
l'esprit quand j'entends cette femme
alors elle est pas uni je vous parle
une vraiment dû à partir de ce qu'on
l'emploie
la punition ça existe ça existe les
femmes qui se sentent punit lorsqu'elle
viennent par exemple parce qu'elle
n'arrive pas à voir l'enfant après avoir
vécu un avortement
elles peuvent avoir ce sentiment que
c'est une punition ça existe
une forme de culpabilité très importante
voilà mais toutes les femmes qui
viennent un cap à ses vrais souffrent le
plus habilité
mais toutes les toutes les femmes qui
ont perdu un bébé quel que soit le terme
au canal lombaire du haut où l'habilité
avec la main comme c'est une perte
volontaire la culpabilité beaucoup plus
première est présente mais c'est à elle
a elle même qu'elle en donne la plupart
du temps essentiellement c'est pas
toujours en référence à des valeurs
c'est cll sont pas en accord avec
quelque chose qui est profondément
ancrée en elle même elle ne font pas
forcément référence à des valeurs
alors pour revenir à ce que vous tissier
par rapport à cette toute cette charge
émotionnelle des femmes que qui parle
dans ce film et qui m'ont beaucoup
touché 1 parce que je sais c'est très
fort et c'est ces affreux quoi de la
situation d'un cas les leçons ce crime
ce qui m'a frappé moi c'est que les
paroles qu'elle dise et les paroles que
nous entendons sa marque dans un pays où
c'est autorisé
oui les entendons tout ce qui concerne
le silence la solitude c'est très très
présent dans les paroles de toutes les
femmes qui viennent parce qu'elle
vehlmann après un avortement il y en a
moi je
je ne vais pas généraliser ce les
personnes qui viennent un il n'ya pas
donc il ya une souffrance elle l'a elle
elles vont pas une culpabilité une
souffrance qu'elles ne vont pas accorder
à la situation d'impossibilité de
difficultés à avorter
c'est c'est vraiment par rapport à leur
vécu
c'est la décision elle-même et pour tous
alors vécu de de l'avortement
c'est à dire que pour elle ça correspond
toujours à une perte pas toujours libre
contrairement à ce qu'on croit peut-être
il ya beaucoup de femmes qui viennent
très en colère donc là on voit beaucoup
de colère du film on comprends cette
colère mais nous il ya de femmes qui
sont très en colère après leur compagnon
après leur mari après des personnes qui
les ont faits leurs envies mais pas
question parce que c'est il ya beaucoup
de femmes qui ont bien du mal à avoir un
enfant ou pas question d'apporter ta
question d'avoir un enfant d'avant et
sans avoir un enfant les femmes qui se
retrouve enceinte sans vouloir sans le
vouloir
voilà c'est un petit peu toute la
question toute la question qui se pose
parce que bien il ya un inconscient qui
parle là il ya des femmes qui désirent
être enceinte
ça me fais avoir certainement parce
qu'on voit le nombre n'a pas non mais ce
que j'entends dans ce que vous racontez
de ces paroles je voudrais avoir votre
avis là-dessus c'est que ça n'est jamais
simple
ça n'est jamais sans douleur je sais que
vous allez régénération là c'est pas
généraliser mois maintenant j'entends
très bien - ya 19 mois n'ont plus l'air
d'un gars pas m'aimer mais la
gynécologue obstétricienne forcément
aussi ces discussions là parce que vous
êtes aussi une écoutante est ce que vous
entendez la même douleur oui je suis de
fait une écoute en tant que
professionnel enfin avant de répondre
précisément la question j'aurais
vraiment féliciter les réalisatrices
parce que ce documentaire il est il est
vrai il est effectivement extrêmement et
mouvement ce témoignage c'est
témoignages de femmes c'est vraiment
bouleversant est vraiment chapeau elle
qu'elle ait pu parce que même en france
alors que la loi ne nourrit il n'y a pas
cette chape de plomb c'est très
difficile d'avoir des femmes qui
témoignent à visage découvert sur ce
parcours
concernant l'avortement qui reste un
sujet tabou ça reste un tabou en france
car absolument absolument arriver
rapidement donc donc c'est pas assez
c'est d'autant plus exemplaire que ces
femmes aient pu et pu parler dans ce
sens s'agissant de je crois que
l'histoire
la question de l'avortement reste une
histoire singulière et qui concerne
c'est des histoires particulières pour
chaque femme il n'y a pas de généralités
sur les motifs d'une décision d'
interrompre une grossesse et je crois
que cette notion de douleur et de
culpabilité dans alors que ça fait
trente ans que je travaille autour de la
question de l'avortement ou que
j'accueille des femmes et que je
pratique ces interruptions de grossesse
ce que je peux voir à travers ça la
détresse et la culpabilité qu'on sait
femme parce que quand elles ont pris la
décision
elles l'ont pris la plupart du temps
sont contraintes elles ont décidé et ces
femmes si les équipes soignantes qui les
reçoivent si le parcours de soins depuis
le premier coup de téléphone jusqu'à la
réalisation de l'acte et culpabilisant à
toutes ses étapes
oui ces femmes vont sortir meurtris de
cette histoire mais la majorité des
femmes je verrai plus de 95 % des femmes
qui demandent un avortement sont décidés
et sont a priori sans culpabilité par
rapport à cette décision qui concerne
leur vie leur choix leur décision il y
interprète des décisions de couples se
tenir sur ces femmes que vous venez
goûter il ya effectivement un petit
nombre de femmes qui vont être dans une
ambivalence certaines qui vont être dans
une difficulté de prendre des décisions
par rapport effectivement à des
pressions externes à une situation de
vie conflictuelle à une fragilité
psychologique qui fait que si elles ne
sont pas écoutés entendus et soutenus
dans leurs démarches pour faire la
clarté sur l'orientation qu'elle doive
prendre qui va pas forcément aboutir à
une interruption de grossesse mais
peut-être indépendamment par nos
gestionnaires non il ya ce processus dès
l'abord avec l'ex vraiment ce gros deux
femmes ambivalente moi je dis non
professionnels la majorité des femmes
qui font la démarche pour interrompre
une grossesse s'est déterminé au moment
où elle arrive elles sont des théâtres 1
15% bleib le petit pourcentage devrait 5
4 à 5% de femmes qui sont dans
une réelle difficulté par rapport à
cette décision vont devoir être
accompagnés pour clarifier les raisons
de ce choix
et elles vont opter soit pour poursuivre
dans ce sens soit pour garder la
grossesse dont vous des 95 % des femmes
qui recourent un avortement aujourd'hui
vont bien après absolument vous dites ça
bien sont même et vous me dis si tenté
avant quel matériel soit accompagnant
sur le plan des chiffres
je veux demander vous voulez dire que
vous accompagnez les femmes que vous
sentez en difficulté par rapport à 7 et
6 ans et notre mission première
c'était ma part tout comme ça écoutez
nous en tout cas c'est une certitude
c'est à dire que nous travaillons dans
cet accompagnement sur la
déculpabilisation des femmes qui ont
fait ce choix là et sur l'accompagnement
est aussi dans la déculpabilisation des
femmes qui sont en difficulté par
rapport à cette grossesse non prévue sur
lesquels elle synthèse sur laquelle elle
s'interroge délai moyen
brigitte gonthier-maurin vont-ils morin
pardon il y a les moyens de faire ce
suivi qui est décrit là parce qu'on il
faudrait des moyens pour faire ce suivi
cds tati tueur est réellement ne crois
pas je ne crois pas je crois qu'il
faudrait beaucoup plus d'endroits où des
femmes puissent être accueillis et
bénéficier de l'ensemble des prestations
qui sont inhérentes à la contraception
est évident dont l'avortement
évidemment non on a une véritable
question de moyens dans notre pays pour
une accession de tout à 7 à l'avortement
au droit au libre choix ou au
libre-choix elles viennent entendre
voilà on peut dire les choses comme ça
laurent tout le monde combien
d'avortement chaque année en france
en ce moment il ya à peu près de 110 me
l'avortement en france donc chaque année
chaque année oui donc c'est un chiffre
qui est à peu près stable qu'il ya un
pied en légère augmentation disons
depuis le milieu des années 90 après
avoir pas mal baissé dans les années 70
et 80
enfin on peut dire qu'en france on est
dans une situation à peu près stable sur
le moyen terme disons en terme de
fréquence des avortements on verra tout
à l'heure ce que ça veut dire la
stabilité du chiffre des avortements
parce que l'une des idées la doua veille
c'est et de la loi neiertz avons la loi
veil c'était la loi sur la contraception
c'était précisément d'éviter qu'un
certain nombre de femmes se retrouvent
confrontés à ce choix là voudraient
qu'on continue à écouter ces saisies
hollandaise sur le poids de l'interdît
et le poids du secret ça m'a beaucoup
frappé vraiment dans votre documentaire
ça revient à plusieurs reprises dans la
bouche des femmes mais aussi du mari est
mort
misery do you know we des deux phrases
par femme n'est pas allé comme nantes et
vannes et saint lys
alors évidemment le des gens qui suivent
comme des criminels c'est assez frappant
pour des français et pour des françaises
mais la force de l'interdît elle est
quasiment biblique
là bas c'est une loi divine si j'ose
dire c'est en tout cas l'impression
qu'on a eus oui ça donne en tout cas
dans votre documentaire mais c'est vrai
que même si c'est un pays de moins en
moins pratiquant la religion reste
extrêmement prégnante dans tous les
aspects de la vie sociale et sociétale
notamment à l'école par exemple dans
beaucoup d'écoles publiques
l'enseignement est encore catholique
l'église à beaucoup que sa parole a
beaucoup de poids dans les débats
donc oui forcément ça il ya une
intériorisation de l'interdît que que je
pense qu'on a moins dans des sociétés
plus plus est clair plus laïcisé voyez
le traitement jusqu'à jeudi mais non est
ce que c'est pas pour nous est ce que
c'est le cas en espagne par exemple on a
vu les espagnols avancent et très forte
sur le chemin du droit à l'avortement et
puis se crisper récemment oui je sais ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure je
crois qu'il ne faut pas considérer que
c'est un droit acquis pour toujours et
que le mouvement des idées doit toujours
être extrêmement affûté pour porter
cette exigence des femmes de disposer de
disposer d'avoir le choix de disposer
d'elle-même et d'avoir un enfant si
elles le souhaitent quand elles le
souhaitent quand elle pense que les
conditions sont le plus réunies
l'obstacle au choix que vous rencontrer
pour vous en france c'est un obstacle
religieux la liberté pour une femme plus
exactement où la liberté pour ces femmes
de faire usage du droit qui est ouvert
par la loi française est ce qu'ils se
heurtent parfois en france à des
obstacles d'ordre religieux non les
interdits d'ordre religieux
c'est interdit son port c'est d'ordre
privé les femmes se l'interdisent a
priori donc on ne les trouve pas dans la
sienne pas vous voir par des ficelles
qui sont dans les centres sont pas du
tout ce poids mais c'est intéressant le
commentaire de ce couple qui nous on
voit comment la culpabilité s'installe
vous on vous dit que vous êtes un
meurtrier dans cette histoire là parce
que là la loi et donc on atteindre cette
notion et toute cette notion de
culpabilité c'est vraiment dans cette
confrontation entre la loi sociétal 1 ce
qui se fait dans une société et
l'étrangeté d'une démarche qui est à
côté de ce qui devrait se faire de la
norme sociétale défini par la société
c'est ça qui marginalise et qui
culpabilise et je crois que même en
france on a cette notion on parle très
facilement d'une naissance on ne parle
pas du fait d'avoir eu un jour un
avortement
on en parle toujours pas on en parle
toujours d'ailleurs je ne me sens pas
libre de vous poser la question aux unes
et aux autres de savoir parce que ça ne
me regarde pas et en même temps vous
n'arriverez pas en me disant moi j'ai
avorté
voilà voilà ça ne se passe pas comme ça
j'aimerais bien intervenir par rapport à
ça les routes plein est-ce que
effectivement ce couple pour nous à
gapan nous accueillons des mâles de deux
couples qui ont perdu un bébé
ils disent bien qu'il ne supporte pas
qu'on appelle leur bébé un foetus et ça
on l'entend très très couramment dans le
groupe de parole est maintenant là vous
avez pas parler d'avortement on est bien
d'accord on parle de coupe qui ont perdu
un enfant au cours d'une grosse c'est
comme ça que vivent les familles nous
avons décidé d'avorter
non je parle de couples qu'ils vous
parlez de la leur vrai 12 avril ils le
disent bien à la fin ils le disent bien
c'est pas une question d'idéologie c'est
pas une question de
de croyance c'est pas une question
sociétale non plus une double histoire
c'est une double peine c'est inouï le
pen et pour eux c'est leur histoire
c'est leur expérience et ses brède je
pense de toute personne qui vit ces jeux
que vous disiez un petit peu tout à
l'heure la culpabilité
j'aimerais bien revenir sur cette
question de la culpabilité parce qu'elle
n'est pas une car elle n'est pas une
culpabilité forcément d'origine ni
sociale ni religieuse a les ailes et que
la femme la femme elle est dans une
toute puissance rapport voyez je
reprends l'image du couple pour le
couple ils ont perdu leur bébé
la femme elle coupable c'est de ne pas
avoir été protégés sont donnés c'est de
se dire que l est
elle aurait dû la toute puissance pour
empêcher que ce bébé ne meurt et
n'arrive pas mais c'est vrai très très
très souvent c'est toujours vrai dans
toutes les pertes anténatal les femmes
elles sont toujours coupable même si
accidentelle elles vont chercher elles
vont chercher qu'est ce que j'ai mangé
qu'est-ce que j'ai parfait pourquoi je
suis pas allé à la maternité
voilà les médecins ont très souvent
beaucoup de mal à la déculpabiliser donc
il ya quand même une culpabilité qui
précise que vous entendez par contre ça
devient à la fois des femmes qui ont
décidé ou qui ont fait ce choix de
l'avortement et des femmes qui ont fait
des fausses couches qui ont perdu leurs
enfants aux cours le passé j'entends
j'étais juste pour préciser que votre
écoute n'était pas limité à lavaur tôt à
l'avortement
je leur en devenir sur l'évolution en
france depuis donc une quarantaine
d'années le droit à l'avortement il
s'est pas fait en un jour et de non
seulement il y avait un combat très
difficile dans les années soixante dix
mais en fait il a fallu une loi dans les
années 80 et noie dans les années 2000
d'une deuxième noir et ça n'est que
maintenant tout récemment que le droit
pour les femmes de recourir
une interruption volontaire de grossesse
est reconnue donc cet aspect de
culpabilisation
non il était c'était on a enlevé la
nounou récemment mais en vérité dans les
faits justement terme de culpabilisation
de dire c'est un droit auquel les femmes
peuvent avoir
disons qu'elles peuvent exercer comme
n'importe quel droit ou bien de dire
dans une situation de détresse quand
vraiment rien d'autre n'est possible ça
peut être envisagée donc il ya vraiment
un changement qui est un changement
récent en france qui est important et on
voit dans nos enquêtes quand on pose des
questions sur l'histoire on pose des
questions aux hommes aux femmes sur l
histoire des personnes ont du mal à
parler des interruptions volontaires de
grossesse qu'elles ont eues et alors ça
peut s'expliquer d'une manière parce que
c'est pas un acte valorisant on peut
dire une ivg de toute façon même si ça
peut permettre de se construire dans une
histoire c'est pas un acte très positif
même les médecins les les
les militants sont un peu fatigués à un
moment c'était une grande victoire pour
les femmes maintenant dix ont transformé
une expérience d'interruption volontaire
de grossesse un dispositif c'est un
travail compliqué mais le fait que ça
soit considéré comme un droit
ça fait quand même une différence énorme
avec la situation de quart landes et
encore une fois même en france c'est
quelque chose de récent et on voit qu'en
espagne c'est même quand il ya eu une
avancée il peut y avoir des retours donc
on est très loin de laisser à sion
certaine manière pour l'interruption des
honduriens soyez d'accord sur l'idée que
même en france est un droit qui peut
bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr pour cours
est très honnête quand j'ai vu le débat
à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat sur
ce sujet l'an dernier je me suis dit
mais tout va bien de pourquoi on
s'affole donc tout ne va pas si bien que
ça ça va bien
par rapport à évidemment des pays qui ne
sont ou l'avortement et n'est pas n'est
pas autorisée est interdite mais il faut
considérer que malte
oui j lo resteront la pologne etc
on a vu ce qui peut arriver ce qui a pu
tenter être tentée en espagne donc
j'affirme qu'il faut vraiment rester est
mobilisé et extrêmement vigilants sur le
don ou à lui-même ouvert par la loi mais
aussi sur les conditions de la
réalisation de l'acte qui vous semblent
pas réunies il ne semblent pas réunies
et sur ce que nous avions abordé tout à
l'heure c'est à dire l'accompagnement
entre
même et un accompagnement qui fait que
vous voyez ce n'est pas un aspect
négatif c'est pas mettre la femme sous
tutelle que je suis en train de dire là
c'est vraiment créer les conditions que
ce soit un acte qui soient le moins
traumatisant possible parce que moi je
cours je continue après en tirer les
leçons je peux me permettre de dire ça
comme ça à alger et route elle moi je
vous laisse quand même il ya quand même
le par rapport au débat que nous avions
tout à l'heure la femme dans notre pays
même si le poids de la religion puisque
nous sommes régis par le principe de la
laïcité n'est pas aussi prégnant que
dans d'autres pays
nous sommes encore vous le disiez très
bien madame vous l'exprimez très bien la
faute originelle entre guillemets c'est
toujours la femme c'est à dire que quand
un couple ils voulaient laquelle la
question d'un avortement de
contraception c'est la ferme un couple
pour moi aussi or cette question là nous
n'arrivons pas à l'imposer
donc c'est tout quand il ya
malformations c'est toujours d'abord à
la femme qu'on pense voilà parce que on
s'inscrit moi j'ai ce sentiment
attention la landec nom d'un conflit
mais je ne me serais pas si je prends
pas cela ces gens viennent ensemble dans
des cas comme cela non bah oui je crois
qu'il faut vraiment faire le distinguo
entre l'interruption volontaire par
décision et de la femme et
l'interruption
dans le cas de malformation d'
indications médicales où on est quand
même dans deux projets différents
c'est très important dans le même projet
et éventuellement à l'origine quoi que m
oui de façon enfin je reviendrai là
dessus mais je voudrais quand même
préciser dans tout ce débat qui avance
que quand même il s'agit d'un droit
fondamental humain de pouvoir décider du
nombre d'enfants combat et quand on les
aura l'espacement de ces grossesses il
faut quand même le rappeler c'est un
droit fondamental humain la deuxième
chose rappeler que tout avortement qui
se pratique dans des conditions
sanitaires impropre aboutissent à des
risques vitaux pour la femme ou des
mutilations avis c'est à dire on a vu ce
qui se passait en france avant 75
passant on voit ce qui se passe encore
dans la majorité des pays être
vers le monde où le droit à l'avortement
sur décision de la femme est interdite
les femmes ont recours à l'avortement
clandestin peut-être pas en irlande
la chape de plomb est tellement immense
et des risques sont tellement immense
mais on a vu qu'en france la loi de 1920
était bafouée et que l'état savait
pertinemment que cette loi a été bafouée
personne ne réagissait mais les femmes
en subissaient les conséquences je crois
qu'il faut rappeler cela et qu'il y à
une urgence pour prendre conscience de
ça qu'il faut et que les l'avortement
troisième notion a toujours existé à
travers le temps à travers les pays et
les religions quelqu'elle soit les
femmes recours à l'avortement quand
elles sont loin ou pas loi confrontée à
une grossesse qui ne fait pas partie de
leur histoire à ce moment précis ces
trois choses étant rappelé il est
important à ce moment là de considérer
l'avortement dans des conditions
sanitaires propres pour éviter des
risques graves chez la femme
indépendamment d'une position féministes
pour devenir le droit de disposer de son
corps ça rejoint le droit humain
fondamental de décider si oui ou non on
a envie d'avoir des enfants et une femme
a le droit de dire je ne veux pas
d'enfant et se retrouvait face à une
grossesse non prévue non désirées face à
l'argument vous venez d'avancé qui est
très clair et qu'on connaît bien en
france parce que c'est l'argument qui a
effectivement présidé à l'adoption de la
loi veil et aux différents en avance et
qui ont eu lieu depuis on voit bien
qu'en irlande sait pas exactement l'état
du débat aujourd'hui avec des
oppositions très dur au parlement et
dans la rue entre les pro choice c'est à
dire les partisans du choix et c'est une
femme d'avorter ou pas et les pro-life
les partisans de la vie
s'appelle louis djalaï la nature nous
voulons que le choix dit ces jeunes
femmes camille à mèze qui me frappe
c'est que ce sont deux générations qui
s'affrontent là oui c'est ça en irlande
c'est en tout cas l'impression qu'on est
ce que c'est ça on a le sentiment que ça
va avancer si j'ose dire ça va bouger
c'est un peu ce qu'on s'attendait à
avoir en arrivant cette image
caricaturale du militants pro-vie
grisonnants souvent des hommes est en
phase de jeunes femmes etc
mais c'est une caricature assez réaliste
en abondance salle tellement une
caricature et voilà c'est passé pas une
caricature en fait c'est en tout cas ce
qu'on a constaté dans les rues et dans
les meetings dans les différents
meetings c'est quand même plus masculins
les plus âgés du côté pro vie et plus
féminin et plus jeune du côté pro choix
cela étant dit c'est vrai que ça donne
de l'espoir pour la suite si je veux
dire selon point de vue dans lequel on
se pose que c'est à dire quels autres
voilà l'intérêt que évidemment un peu
militant je pense qu'on ne s'en cache
pas dans le film
non mais il faut quand même bien
comprendre que ces deux pôles du débat
ce nombre représente pas du tout la
majorité de ce que pensent les irlandais
que pensent les irlandais au milieu de
tout ça alors je ne vais pas parler pour
le peuple irlandais ça n'aurait pas de
sens mais d'après les sondages les
discussions qu'on a eues etc
on peut quand même se dire que la
plupart des gens une position assez
nuancée c'est à dire ce qui est c'est
d'ailleurs assez difficile à comprendre
je pense en france c'est à dire qu'ils
sont d'accord ils seraient d'accord pour
que l'avortement soit autorisé en cas de
danger pour la santé de la vie de la
femme en cas d'inceste en cas de viol
en cas de malformation du foetus mais il
n'est pas du tout question pour
l'instant d'accorder le droit à
l'avortement de moins de choix voilà
donc droit de choisir sa une en même
majoritairement pas question d'après les
sondages je crois que ça serait de
l'ordre de 20% de la peau de mémoire
de la population qui supporterait l'idée
du choix on est capable laurent tout le
monde de dire ce que représentent les
partisans dit de la vie les pro-life en
france alors en france ils sont très peu
nombreux
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que où la
sensibilité qui le représente pas ce que
vous donnez de luri les militants et
puis un certain temps les gens pas des
années 70 il y avait des arguments de
nature très différente qui circulait
donc il y avait des arguments de nature
religieuse des arguments moraux des
arguments pragmatique des arguments
démographiques et donc c'est très
difficile de savoir comment et c'est la
gloire d'une certaine façon de la
république d'arriver à avoir des débats
qui font que le public peut changer
aussi donc
mais en france on n'est pas du tout dans
la situation du moment de cirque on a
vraiment l'impression qu' il y avait un
mouvement non seulement des femmes qui
allaient recourir à l'avortement à
l'étranger mais aussi il y avait un
soutien disons de même si c'était comme
une ministre d'un gouvernement de droite
qui était pas soutenu par sa majorité
mais elle était soutenue par son
président fin c'était une situation
quand même très lentes et ma liste et
elles étaient soutenues voilà par le mot
féminisme est arrivé certains partis de
gauche au début enfin disons que c'était
vraiment quelque chose de deux complexes
donc c'est un peu compliqué de voir
quelle disons l'opinion elle se pose par
rapport à une alternative et on voit
bien que en irlande
l'alternative c'est des situations qui
nous nous paraissent vraiment tellement
extrême que l'on a du mal à les imaginer
enfin c'est la force de votre reportage
on voit que vraiment on a vraiment du
mal à se demander si c'est vraiment ça
la situation là en france on était quand
même dans une situation différente mais
il y avait une non-parution qu'il y
avait une inquiétude sur est-ce que
s'ils ont libéralisé l'avortement il y
aurait plus d'avortements risque qu'il y
aurait moins de l'essence ça me faisait
partie du débat et là dessus je crois
que dit le démographe produits on peut
dire que là où l'avortement est autorisé
il n'y a pas plus d'avortements que là
où il est interdit
il y en a plus que là où c'est interdit
et on peut dire que là où l'avortement
est autorisé il ya plutôt disons quand
il ya beaucoup d'avortement il ya plutôt
beaucoup de naissances
si on veut faire une relation à
l'échelle des populations on peut dire
dans les pays d'europe où il ya peu
d'avortement ceux des pays où il ya peu
de naissance dans les années où il ya
beaucoup d'avortement c'est aussi des
années où il ya beaucoup de naissances
donc à l'échelle des populations donc ça
aussi ça fait partie de la complexe
une question qui était un peu qu est un
peu compliqué mais ça veut dire qu'il ya
un nombre incompressibles que
l'avortement ferait partie de la vie qui
aurait un nom alors ré cible j'aurais
tendance à dire exactement 3 d'abord si
l'avortement est un droit à la question
du nombre incompressible est une
question qui n'est pas forcément
pertinente
ensuite le nombre est pas vraiment un
conte précis puisqu'on voit en france
par exemple d'une à l'autre il ya des
différences très importantes
pratiquement de 2 à 3 en termes de
fréquence de l'avortement dans les pays
d'europe il ya aussi des variations très
importantes
donc on peut dire qu'il ya des
contrastes importants mais en termes de
dévolution les encore une fois à
l'échelle des populations plus il ya de
contraception moins il ya de recours à
l'avortement mais en france par exemple
ait dans beaucoup d'autres pays
d'ailleurs la diffusion de la pilule du
lendemain dans certains pays a permis de
court a conduit à une diminution du
nombre des ivg dans d'autres pays n'a
pas conduit à une diminution du nombre
d'usagers c'est le cas en france
alors est ce que c'est un sur ses échecs
et à voir quelle est leur donnez moi
parce que c'est vrai c'est vivre c'est à
pour la di milano d'arrêt je ne sais pas
du tout évident de gommer ça c'est pas
de danse et on est dans un pays où
finalement le droit est en place et
pourtant le nombre d'avortements ne
baisse pas parce que peut-être il ya un
problème d'accès à l'information pour
les jeunes adolescents sur l'avortement
sur la contraception la contraception
sur la contraception d'abord est ce que
dit le professeur israël nisand par
exemple qu'il y ait un problème avec les
jeunes adolescentes pour qui aujourd'hui
l'avortement est devenu pardon de le
dire aussi brutalement une forme de
contraception c'est vrai moi je ne suis
pas je ne nagerai pas en tant que
professionnel ce point de vue parce que
je crois que c'est encore une fois
affaire d'individus il ya des
adolescentes extrêmement responsables
qui prennent et puis y ait des
adolescentes et les aident les simples
ne sont pas différentes des autres
femmes et l'avortement ne concerne pas
que les adolescentes parce que il ya un
focus sur des adolescentes
je peux dire quand même que la
les étudiants quelle est la proportion
un avortement sur deux hommes de moins
de 35 ans je me trompe
oui c'est même un peu plus disons c'est
vrai que depuis une dizaine d'années le
recours à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse a plutôt augmenté avant 25 ans
parce que d'un côté des naissances
arrive de plus en plus tard dans la vie
des femmes et donc il ya une période ils
ont entre les premiers rapports sexuels
et puis le souhait d'avoir une première
naissance qui est beaucoup plus longues
que par le passé donc ça explique de
façon tout à fait simple disons que le
recours à une ivg et les augmenter mais
on le lien des classiques de prévention
sur la contrainte et sexualité beaucoup
plus active entre 17 et 25 ans ça
s'explique par toutes ces raisons
auraient effectivement l'arrivée de la
première grossesse qui est plutôt autour
de 30 ans en france il ya cette langue
perd rien d'un contraceptif et qui fait
que donc il ya effectivement plus il ya
plus de fertilité aussi à ces âges là
donc tout concourt à faire qu'il n'y a
plus un échec pour vous autrement dit
non moi je pense et ma question je
claque quand même des questions
d'éducation tout de même parce que j'ai
souvenir d'avoir reçu plusieurs tout
jeune femme qui qui disait de tout
simplement que s'imaginer à quel pouvait
être enceinte en ayant une vie sexuelle
où elle prenait la pilule et on peut
être enceinte avec la pilule est donc
c'était c'était une surprise vraiment
pas ce que parce que je n'ai pas envie
d'être mère je ne serai pas en simple
dans ma vie sexuelle
7 cette affirmation qui était un peu
particulière tout même même si je veux
pas la généraliser mais je n'ai entendu
deux fois non je vais au puy
je m'imaginais pas que je pouvais être
mère donc je n'imaginais pas que je
pouvais tension la peur de la grossesse
à mon avis a disparu quand même dans
chez les jeunes qui ont une vie sexuelle
il ya des classes vous poser avant de
clore ce débat absolument passionnant et
qui vous aura passionné j'en suis sûr il
ya des femmes qui prennent le bateau ou
qui prennent l'avion des françaises qui
prennent le bateau ou l'avion pour
avorter aujourd'hui puisque au delà de
12 semaines qu'ils quittent le
territoire bien sûr elles existent
encore ces femmes en dépit de la réforme
de 2001 de la loi qui allonger les
délais il ya certaines femmes du fait
d'une baisse de l'offre de dire passé
mais pas assez de centaines de face et
ses réparties de façon inégale sur le
territoire certaines zones sont vraiment
en déficit de deux centres d'accueil et
d'orientation pour ces femmes donc le
temps passe très vite
et ces femmes peuvent se retrouver hors
délai en france il ya encore en 2015 des
femmes qui doit voir si bien tu centres
de planning familial en disant moins 130
mois 130 planning familial seulement je
ne parle pas des opérations de
regroupement d'hôpitaux qui font suite à
la loi hpst
donc il ya vraiment un problème de
moyens c'est il faut vraiment essayer de
saisir ce questionnement je vais rester
hôpital santé territoire
au passage merci à tous les âges toutes
les 5 à tous les cinq noms à tous les
saints car le masculin s'impose même
dans des débats comme vous pouvez
continuer et si vous voulez vous pouvez
continuer le débat sur le mail de
l'émission qui s'affiche évidemment
comme d'habitude en en bas de votre
écran vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux
à le faire d'ailleurs
et merci beaucoup parce que ça nous
permet de prolonger le débat
la semaine prochaine vous retrouvez
claire barsacq pour un docu débat
consacré ça vous intéressera aussi sans
doute aux addictions technologiques les
portables les écrans etc
oui ça aussi c'est un sujet à très vite
sur public sénat
le on sait